bitcoin has been falling very
aggressively and there's a lot of people
who are out there spreading all sorts of
rumors fud uncertainty and doubt what
exactly is the data saying though if we
go ahead and we take a look we know that
bitcoin the digital decentralized
currency it just posted its worst
quarter of performance since 2011.
bitcoin plunging 58
in this quarter is obviously incredibly
painful to many of the people who are
holding it but what we do know is that
most bitcoiners regardless of if there's
volatility to the upside or the downside
they aren't actually selling the asset
yes the price has come down but all the
underlying fundamentals continue to
strengthen everything from hash rate to
bitcoins lightning network capacity to
even wallet addresses on chain with
various amounts of bitcoin hitting
all-time highs the underlying
fundamentals continue to get stronger
even though price is dropping if we go
ahead and we take a look over here at
fungstrat we've got a quote from mark
newton bitcoin has had good success over
the last dozen years and making cyclical
lows every 90 weeks lows should be right
around the corner according to the cycle
composite and one should be on alert in
the month of july looking to buy
weakness for a healthy rebound just as
sentiment seems to be reaching a bearish
tipping point now naturally you can only
look at data in a backwards looking
fashion we don't know what the future
holds bitcoin is a decentralized digital
currency it appears to be incredibly
valuable for many many people around the
world over 150 million people are
estimated to now hold bitcoin but it
just posted the worst quarter since
2011.
that means all the critics all the
naysayers all those people who think
it's going to zero they're doing victory
laps on the internet right now they
think they're dancing on graves but they
also thought that in every other bear
market previously sometimes you have to
zoom out you have to actually look and
ask yourself is my thesis is my analysis
of this asset of this market of the
macro environment still valid do i still
believe what i believed previously and
what i think we're seeing is that many
bitcoiners not only do they believe what
they previously said but they actually
think that much of what's breaking
across the macro environment is simply
proving what their predictions were
previously so there you have it bitcoin
the worst quarter in over a decade but
that doesn't mean bitcoin's going away
in fact bitcoin's stronger than ever and
i tend to think that more and more
people start closing their eyes to the
price in the bear market they start
paying attention to what's actually
important adoption and adoption only
seems to be headed in one way up and to
the right hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time